So, she's learning how to silky plow.
We're going to follow them around for
about seven minutes while we also learn
a few things about about the silky
plow. I'm at Tillers International
today, which is a training center for
historic farm skills like the Sulky
Plow.
Hi, my name is Chuck. The channel is
around Van Beern and today we're talking
about the Sulki plow. They're working a
twoacre plot along with other uh
volunteer draft horse teams.
Today I caught up with Cody in the
Tillers International woodworking shop
and this is what he told me. How tillers
international started. It was a forum
for training draft animals. And so that
two acres out there is sort of what ties
everything together. It's where we
practice those historic skills and make
them come alive. People are welcome to
come here and to learn these historic
skills for whatever reason that they
have. Maybe they want to use them on
their own market garden farm or maybe
they just want they're curious and they
want to have the joy of learning.
The sulky plow was invented by the John
Deere company in
1875 and since then it's been built by
many other companies.
She's leading the team. Although it
seems like the horse on the right is a
leader, too.
Thank you for coming out. I'm Cody. Hey,
Cody. I'm Darren. Darren, I think we met
just Yeah, we have met before, I think.
But yeah,
are you farm manager? Is that what what
is that what you're talking? What do you
do?
[Music]
Okay.
But I hoped uh we have uh a couple of
sections of Ry and then you can see this
hairy bench.
Today, one of the manufacturers of sulky
plows is Pioneer
Equipment. Another company that makes
sulky plows today is White Horse
Machine. Here's a picture of one of the
the White Horse machine uh sulky plows.
It can plow 10 to 12 acres a day.
I was looking online for instructions on
how to use the Sulky plow.
Uh, I've got a link that's uh about as
close as I can get, but I think your
best bet is to uh sign up with killers
international.org for one of their
training sessions.
If you visit um Killers International
outside, it's out of Kazoo,
Michigan, they've got camping and
rooming. I don't I don't understand
entirely, but contact them.
Also, in the
southeast corner of
Kazoo, there's plenty of hotels, and
that's a short drive away from
uh Children's International.
Other teams are out today practicing
their skills and demonstrating draft
animals as well.
Oh, blacksmith at Tillers International
is very helpful and uh he explained more
about how things work.
From tiller's program's perspective, we
work with people from other countries
frequently where there's not a dealer
where you can get parts for repairing
your farm equipment. Yeah. So the pieces
sometimes are locally manufactured or
sometimes they're imported from
somewhere else. But if something breaks,
the only way you're getting it fixed is
to go to the village blacksmith just
like they did in this country in the old
days. Yeah. And get them to make a new
part or repair the piece you have. And
so sometimes it might be a modern repair
like an arc weld, but it could often be
just done with rivets or bolts or
something involve working in a forge
like this one. Mhm. You're heating the
parts up to bend them around, change the
shape.
Okay, good. Thank you. Okay, nice
talking to you.
for their farming program. Tillers
International trains
anyone. Small
farms, truck patch
farms, subsistence
farmers, homesteaders,
preppers,
self-sufficient
survivalist,
off-grid, international
farmers, organic
farmers. Who did I
miss? The Amish use horsedrawn farm
implements like this all the time, but
they grow up with
it. For horserawn equipment, teams can
consist of two, three, or four horses.
The number of horses used depends on the
equipment and the weight that's being
pulled. A common setup is two horses
hitched side by
side. In this case, we have four horses
hitched side by side.
And sometimes the four horse hitch would
consist of two teams, one in front of
the other.
Early sulky plows like the Oliver turned
uh 12, 14 or 16inch furrows and were
pulled by three horses or
mules. Axle grease reduced friction.
Modern silky plows might have a dozen or
more grease
fittings. Now we're going to see her in
the driver's seat.
Thanks for watching. Looking forward to
reading your comments about the Sulki
Plow. Be sure to like and subscribe.
I'll see you next time.